number one
he called you a cowboy what did he mean
why are you just a humble bounty hunter
ma'am you started out so fearlessly go
pull the trigger I don't think I blow
the boundary I blow you away sorry I've
got no time to play around with you guys
don't pull that part of crap on these
time of those
[Music]
- one it's channel spike Spiegel from
Cowboy Bebop
[Music]
okay okay I put spike at the top was it
predictable yes did a bajillion of you
guys call it already yes is your
personal coolest anime character
infinitely more underground than mine
yes but you know what I don't care when
I started this list I also didn't really
want to put spike at the top either
because that would be too obvious but no
matter how many characters are
researched no matter how many times I've
thought about it and no matter what
criteria put all the characters through
spike always came out on top and while I
know many people will be disappointed
and will feel this is a bit
anticlimactic [ __ ] if he was that
obviously number one that is that not
enough of a reason to put him there cuz
in a series that loses coolness out of
every orifice and even makes losing
orifices look cool Cowboy Bebop may not
have invented the rule of cool but why
God did they perfect it with a fusion of
music and film using a soundtrack that
still beats the crap out of 90% of every
anime ever made every second of the show
reeks of style and jazz with a
character-driven plot that redefined how
cool an anime could be and a character
that epitomizes all the cool things in
this show is most definitely this guy so
do I really need to explain why he's
number one as a 27 year old bounty
hunter born on Mars spike was once a
rising member of the red dragon crime
syndicate so after falling in love he
tried to escape their grasp by faking
his own death after which he teamed up
with former ISSP officer jet black on
his ship the bebop to start his career
as a bounty hunter not so successful
bounty hunter but enough the past
everyone already knows
since the important thing is everything
about this guy radiates an aura of
coolness that I haven't seen before him
or since though that's what individual
traits are make him cool you've already
seen a lot of these before and other
characters on his countdown ignoring his
coolest he has a fighting style inspired
by Bruce Lee's Jeet Kune though making
him smooth as water when it comes to
hand-to-hand combat on top of this he
has the skills of a top marksman with
his pistols and is also skilled pilot
with his trusty spaceship so is there
anything this guy can't do not to
mention err this marks the hat-trick for
Speed Blues appearance on this countdown
portraying spike with a voice so sexy
they could possibly have babies with it
he give through such a casual and
laid-back attitude about everything he
does even in the face of his own death
because in his own words whatever
happens
where he lives by the philosophy of
taking life one day at a time and I
would have a hard time picking just one
clip to show of his iSchool voice and
attitude since he could basically quote
anything he says he'll be cool in some
way what are you going to do just throw
your life away like it was nothing
I'm not going there to die I'm going to
find out if I'm really alive but really
what made him constantly jump back to
number one is that even though we've
already seen all these cool traits
before word previous characters he has
everything refined to a tee the suave
and sleek look of LuPone without those
sideburns and they call her hairstyle
the bad aspects of Mugen without the
hotheadedness the smooth fighting style
of hey without turning into a hobo the
marksmanship of vash without the
goofiness the laid-back attitude of
Onizuka without the Onizuka and the
charisma and charm of Johann and the
count without the cross-dressing or
casual pedophilia tell me what you're
doing here let's flip a coin as I tell
you tails we go out on a date are all
the employees here like you you get some
pretty classy moves for a corporate girl
the more that you know the shorter your
life will be I love the kind of woman
that can kick my ass yes we'll all these
coolest traits contained within this one
fictional character it would be hard to
find a real-life actor that would be
able to bring all that coolness that was
portrayed in the anime which is why when
I first heard Keanu Reeves was cast as
spike in a rumored live-action version
my hopes for him being able to capture
just one iota of his coolness of the
anime counterpart whereas abysmal as he
thought it was and it sounded something
like this but you never know since with
this history he's been able to portray a
wide range of characters with his acting
skills I mean there's happy Keanu Reeves
store determined Keanu Reeves store
Chinese Keanu Reeves funny shirt
shooting surprise Keanu Reeves whoa
excited Keanu Reeves well complete
confuse the Burmese by cemetery city's
patent fee and anticipation of death
Keanu Reeves whoa I'd even gauge your
ease
yeah this is gonna suck isn't it now
some of you guys might be wanting to put
him down slightly since unlike some of
the other guys in this countdown he
isn't invincible or unfeasible as we see
a few times that he's only human and he
can't get injured and outclassed at
times but honestly it doesn't really
matter to me because if he was
completely indestructible like some
other guys then we wouldn't have seen
one of the most iconic if not the
coolest death at Ministry of anime after
facing his past and single-handedly
making a skyscraper full of merciless
syndicate killers his [ __ ] he faces off
against his rival in a brief nasty but
very coolly executed duel a duel that he
wins but also results in him parts of
ways in a simple gets a badass fashion
that was so perfect for him we wouldn't
have it any other way and all it took
was one dying work that has been
engraved in every anime fan who's
watched this and would forever cement
him as the coolest anime character ever
we all miss you spike
but for now we'll see you space cowboy
so that was my countdown of the top 20
epically cool anime characters it's over
I hope it was this epic and cool as
advertised and I hope you guys don't
hate me too much for putting spike at
the top cuz I admit you had the idea for
this countdown a freaking year ago last
Christmas holiday so I've been working
on this count now for a freaking year
now so I have to quite a bit of thought
into this but even though did put a lot
of thought into this I'm sure I've
missed someone so if you think I've
missed anyone or you just want to do
your own cat then you know feel free to
post your own video response so if you
watched all the parts which is almost 2
hours of me talking congratulations you
need to get alive 101 that says about
the person who made all these videos
no but seriously if you watch all the
videos and thanks for sticking around
with my [ __ ] and if you haven't then
you can start off here I guess but as
for me well you can expect more reviews
and Ransom maybe some more countdown
which are a lot less short so the future
so until then I hope you had fun with
this countdown and I'll see you all next
time
[Music]